let's check in with a couple of other
people here we are taking your calls at
6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 we will take our next
caller who is are you calling from New
Hampshire might I be right about that no
I'm actually in Salisbury Massachusetts
oh okay all right you have a New
Hampshire number maybe yeah sure do cool
what's going on alright Oh my name is
Grady McDonald and I was calling in a
talk about this hypothetical going
around about banning Trump from Twitter
for speech backlash notwithstanding do
you think that the ban would constitute
a public good especially in the wake of
Twitter's spokesperson affirming that
the Tos applies to everyone including
verified accounts well one thing what is
the argument what's the argument that
that is being made what is Trump
tweeting that would justify a ban based
on the Terms of Service well you could
definitely take a look at how he kind of
from a removed position incites hate
speech hateful acts definitely is guilty
of targeting people as he calls out
members of the press and other people
who are critical of him but I think the
important function of banning him from
Twitter would be forcing him to actually
have to address a press corps in person
have prepared remarks or at least be
more accountable for his behavior and
his ideas whereas if he shoots stuff off
at 3:00 in the morning you can backtrack
delete and chalk it up to just being
Twitter right listen so a couple of
thoughts on this one yes there would be
an insane freedom of speech First
Amendment backlash if that happened and
that would be incorrect because we're
talking about Twitter they have a Terms
of Service they can decide what users
are allowed and what users are not
allowed I think that you know Twitter
banning him for the sole purpose of
forcing him to have to face the press
corps I think that that they would be
severely critiqued for that because that
would be actually manipulating the Terms
of Service to serve some kind of
political aim but you're talking about
stochastic hate speech which is the idea
that he's not actually doing hate speech
himself but because of the number of
followers he have it
has in their sensibilities and the
topics he's talking about he is
indirectly likely to be inspiring some
people to participate in hate speech I
don't think that this is too strong
though Pat it looks like you have
thoughts on this well the other thing
too is that there's a separate Twitter
account for the President of the United
States that he's poised to inherit know
how funny would it be if they have to
cancel that account because the
president is inciting hate speech well
he could Rachel tweet on his personal
account the stuff that's relates to the
deals and then he tweets on the POTUS
account stuff that relates to being
president and hey no more conflicts of
interest because it's two separate
Twitter accounts right yeah that would
be the ultimate hypocrisy though on his
part if it does get banned because he'll
he'll say that this is infringing on my
free speech when he is the king of that
very interesting question I think that
they should tread carefully mostly
because of the PR of banning the
president-elect or president from from
Twitter but really interesting question
thanks so much from the call for from
Salsbury mass always good to check in
with Salsbury all right thanks so much